INFORMANT WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE
INFORMANT WILL BE MADE AVAILABL
AVAILABLE.
BRET.
>> Bret: CATHERINE, THINK HE
APPEARED MORE ON THIS WITH THE
PANEL.
WALL STREET HAD A BIG DAY ON
NEWS OF A POSSIBLE TRADE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
CHINA.
DOW GAINED 298.
S&P 500 UP 20.
NASDAQ FINISHED AHEAD 40.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CELEBRATING
THE DEVELOPMENT BUT SOME EXPERTS
ARE SAYING CHINA MAY BE PULLING
A FAST ONE ON THE U.S., AND
THERE'S ALREADY A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF HEDGING FROM BOTH
SIDES TONIGHT.
CORRESPONDENT KRISTIN FISHER
REPORTS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS EVENING.
>> BEFORE PRESIDING OVER THE
SWEARING-IN CEREMONY OF THE NEW
CIA DIRECTOR GINA HASPEL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNLOADED ON
TWITTER ABOUT HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH TO
RESOLVING A TRADE WAR WITH
CHINA.
NOTING THAT CHINA HAS AGREED TO
BUY MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
ADDITIONAL FARM AND AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS AND THAT BARRIERS AND
TARIFFS WILL COME DOWN.
AFTER MONTHS OF THREATENING TO
IMPOSE TIP TARIFFS ON CHINESE
STEEL AND ALUMINUM WITH HIM OF
THE TREASURY SECRETARY MADE THIS
BOLD DECLARATION ON FOX NEWS
SUNDAY.
>> WHERE PUTTING THE TRADE WAR
ON HOLD.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AGREED TO PUT
THE TARIFFS ON HOLD WHILE WE TRY
TO EXECUTE THE FRAMEWORK.
>> SECRETARIES TO BE 23 SAYS THE
AGREEMENT INCLUDES TRYING TO
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE THE TRADE
DEFICIT.
WHEN ASKED EXACTLY BY HOW MUCH,
THE SECRETARY WOULDN'T SAY.
>> THERE'S A REASON WHY WE
DIDN'T PUT A SPECIFIC NUMBER ON
IT.
THE SPECIFIC NUMBER, AGAIN,
WHATEVER WE AGREED TO, THESE ARE
NOT GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
PURCHASES.
WE HAVE VERY SPECIFIC TARGETS
INDUSTRY BY INDUSTRY.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
DESCRIBES LAST WEEK TALKS WITH
THE CHINESE AND THE FREE MARKET
PRODUCED A SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS IN THE MARKETS
RESPONDED ACCORDINGLY.
FEARS ABOUT GLOBAL TRADE WAR
BETWEEN THE WORLD'S TWO BIGGEST
ECONOMIES SUBSIDED.
TODAY THERE ARE BIPARTISAN FEARS
THAT THIS POTENTIAL DEAL IS
LETTING THE CHINESE OFF THE HOOK
ON ONE OF ITS BIGGEST
TRANSGRESSIONS.
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHUCK URGED
THAT TRUMP ADMINISTERED AND
CANNOT TELL A VERDICT TEMPORARY
PURCHASE OF GOODS WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE REAL ISSUE, THE
THEFT OF AMERICAN INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
WHILE REPUBLICAN SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO SAID ANY DEAL THAT DOESN'T
STOP CHINA FROM CYBER THEFT AND
FORCING U.S. COMPANIES TO
TRANSFER TECHNOLOGY TO THEM IS A
HUGE LOSS.
IT'S UNCLEAR IF THAT ISSUE, THE
THEFT OF AMERICAN INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY, IS STILL ON THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
AS TO WHAT'S NEXT, THE COMMERCE
SECRETARY WILBUR ROSS IS HEADING
TO CHINA NEXT WEEK TO TRY TO
TURN THE INITIAL FRAMEWORK INTO
AN ACTUAL SIGNED AGREEMENT.